here for reaction former energy
secretary and texas governor
rick perry governor thanks for being
here you saw that map that's more than
half the country nbc's trying to peg it
on climate change what do you make of
potential now
power blackouts
well this is clear uh we've been talking
about this for a long time
uh you have to have base load you know
diversity is fine in the energy side of
things it's it's good to have a portion
of your energy that comes from wind it's
good to have a portion of it comes from
solar but you must have
a base load of energy uh to keep the
lights on when the wind doesn't blow and
when the sun doesn't shine and that's
going to happen so to face up to that
fossil fuels are going to be a very
important part of that and nuclear when
you think about who
the
left really doesn't like what industries
they don't like in the power generation
side of it fossil fuels is the top of it
and nuclear power is is number two a
close number two i might yeah so until
you get a
a nuclear power system into place and
we've got the technology pete it's it's
stunning to me that we can't
put small modular reactors out there you
know there's a host of companies and a
host of technology uh that's out there
today that could address this i hope
some states will take uh the lead on
this if the federal government's going
to make it so hard to get a permit for a
a small mighty reactor then the states
need to take this into their hand for
instance texas we own our own grid we
need to step forward using the 10th
amendment and say you know what
washington you're not going to do this
we're going to take care of this
ourselves and go forward with it
senator everything you said makes sense
to me i totally get it but between
increasing refinery capacity and new
nuclear plants we're talking years maybe
decades what are folks supposed to do
this summer when it gets hot and the
power goes up by a fan like what what is
the strategy
yeah well i mean listen this this is an
incredibly difficult period of time uh
what we have seen is our country taking
its eye away from
power
distribution power development
putting way too many eggs in the basket
of wind and solar i mean i i need to be
blunt about it we put too much focus on
that we need to be sending the messages
to those
that can build quickly peaker plants for
instance you use natural gas we've got
you know literally hundreds of years of
natural gas in this country it's it's a
clean burning fuel we need to be using
that instead of listening to the john
kerry's of the world who you know they
they uh
do what i say not what i do when it
comes to the flying around the world on
your jet and then getting out and
lecturing us about uh how bad fossil
fuels are i mean it's it's it's
stunningly uh ignorant of them to think
that the american people are going to
buy that you have the secretary of
energy that's out telling the energy
industry on one hand we want you to go
produce more and then
we're going to shut you down in five to
seven years
it's just that's what i was going to say
you're exactly right and my solution to
buying a fan not even going to work in
that scenario because you can't plug it
in governor thank you very much
appreciate it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else